[Music]
okay Robert Pattinson what do you got
Cosmopolis is directed by David
Cronenberg and stars Robert Pattinson
this is a movie that I've heard so many
different things about largely mixed a
lot of festivals showed this film and
people were just walking out of it like
like in some trance like what what was
that like what just happened to my body
and knowing David Cronenberg's work and
being a fan of his work I thought yeah
that makes sense I mean a lot of his
movies are really trippy and odd Robert
Pattinson plays a businessman of some
kind it's not entirely clear and just
that he has large sums of money to go
through his office and he's extremely
rich and the first scene in the film he
says we need a haircut he gets in his
giant stretch limo and he basically
drives throughout the entire city and
countering various people that he knows
and increasingly more strange situations
now as I said I'm a fan of David
Cronenberg's work I love the deadzone
Christopher Walken the fly Eastern
Promises and my favorite film of his is
probably a history of violence I think
he's a terrific director and this film
still has that same great visual look
that all this films have excellent
framing immaculate use of focus like
it's insane how well shot this film is
it all looks great lots of long takes
with actors just talking to each other
without cutting and you really get that
kind of theater feel like it's a play or
something that being said this movie
really lost me on a lot of levels
basically script in story elements first
off I'll just tell you this Robert
Pattinson really good in this movie he
gave a really legitimately good
performance I was really impressed with
him in fact all the acting all around
it's great but particularly him and Paul
Giamatti even though apology Maya
doesn't have a huge part in this movie
about this script it makes no sense yeah
I don't know what they're talking about
I have no problem eating that I honestly
barely understood a thing in this movie
people rattle off extremely long
conversations filled with muddled
dialogue that no human can decipher or
understand unless you sit there and
actually like physically read the script
with a dictionary in your left hand the
script in your right and you're looking
left to right like okay that that would
that means that that means okay you're
gonna feel pretty stupid when you watch
this movie I mean you may even start to
drool a little bit and the other theater
you're just like oh I like when you're
walking out because it just it totally
melted your brain
it's so difficult to understand what
anyone's talking about in this movie so
you can't really grasp any central plot
or a story it's just insane people
driving around in the city to the best
of my knowledge I could figure out this
movie is not a drama as it says on IMDB
this is a fantasy because characters are
riding the line of credibility endlessly
throughout this movie his limo drives
throughout the city at a snail pace and
yet throughout this film he continuously
encounters his wife all throughout the
city at various points and she's just
there she just keeps appearing magically
like some ghost throughout the city
where he just happens to be other people
who have no way of knowing where Robert
Pattinson will be in the city are just
there for him to be there's somebody
trying to assassinate him who just so
happens to have an apartment that is
absolutely disgusting and dilapidated
and he just so happens to have an
apartment like right next to where
Robert Pattinson parks his car this does
not happen in real life this movie's a
fantasy this isn't a realistic movie at
all over the course of this one day
Pattinson 's character takes such a
decline of morality for no reason
there's there's no explanation for why
he just starts doing these things that
he does
they never discuss it they never allow
characters to go in depth about it it
just happens this is based off a book
and from what I've heard the book is
very similar and a lot of people have
said that this is the best adaptation
you could have made of the source
material because the source material is
as jumbled and strange and weird as this
is and I understand that but to me the
most important part of a film is the
story if you're not interested in the
story you're not gonna care if the
performances are good you're not gonna
care if the movie looks incredible if
you are bored or confused by the central
story it has no weight and as far as I
can tell this movie has no actual story
or plot that sometimes works for films
that have incredibly good dialogue for
instance look at Seinfeld okay
each episode does have a little plot and
everything but it's mostly just them
just talking about random stuff and it's
hilarious
a lot of Quinton Tarantino's dialogue is
like that too where there isn't like one
central huge plot but there's incredible
dialogue and characters that you like
Cosmopolis has no real story and the
dialogue is incomprehensible it doesn't
seem to go anywhere and when it
ends pretty much my entire audience went
like I'm not kidding there was an
audible moan throughout the theater when
it ended the movie has things that are
great about it and it's mostly all
technical aspects of the way it looks
and the way it was made but from a story
standpoint it fails so miserably I'm
gonna give Cosmopolis a seed really
because of the technical aspects of the
film and the good performances but if
you honestly like going to movies so
that you can understand what in the
world they're talking about this is not
the movie for you
thanks for watching guys and as always
if you like this then you can click
right here and get stuck mini eyes
[Music]